[Music]
buried here is a man who died before his
time his grave a monument to ignorance
and fraud there was little to be done
about John Martin stupidity but
ultimately there was an answer to
another man's deceit John Martin who
clipped an ad and sent away for a bottle
of Medicine died of a common disease and
yet you might also say he was murdered
murdered as surely as though the deed
had been done by bullet or knife
but John Martin deceased was not the
only one who had seen that and it also
came to the attention of some interested
people in food and drug administration
shington operating under the Federal
Security Agency its aims to combat filth
and fraud in our food products and to
guarantee as best it can that medicines
and cosmetics not only contain what the
makers say they contained but do what
the makers claim they'll do
and so to a bureau official comes an ad
clip from a newspaper relief at last a
remedy for diabetes arthritis kidney
disorders and well it was a suspiciously
long list of guarantees and a matter for
the nearest regional office to check
into a network of 16 district stations
covers the country and from the New York
office
inspector Kennedy starting out with only
a small advertisement launches the chain
of events which will determine how much
validity if any there is in the claims
of a preparation called elixir X
[Applause]
in a small industrial city inspector
Kennedy locates the manufacturer but his
wife says he's out of town be gone two
weeks perhaps maybe a month sure she'll
show him where the elixir X is made is
right back in the garage the Food and
Drug Administration FDA is constantly
ferreting out products manufactured
under filthy and unsanitary conditions
for at the moment this is not Kennedy's
primary objective he subsequently asks
the woman for a list of her husband's
customers but she insists that she knows
nothing about any such list wouldn't
even know where to look for one
[Applause]
but inspector Kennedy doesn't wait for
his man to return like skinning a cat
there is more than one way to rundown
evidence so Kennedy sets out on some
tedious legwork starting with a local
trucking company he tries to uncover
shipping orders to distributors or even
individual orders which to avoid postal
involvement often hour sent a bottle or
two at a time by Express after going
through mountains of Records his
patience is finally rewarded he finds
half a dozen orders three of which are
in his own district
now begins the second phase of inspector
Kennedy's task the gathering of evidence
that will stand up in court if necessary
proof that elixir X was bought and used
yes she has used it regularly this lady
told him in another town best thing
she'd found yet for her arthritis matter
of fact she just finished the bottle and
has to send away for another
[Music]
[Applause]
two days later Kennedy makes a real
strike her husband had been using elixir
ex regularly said mrs. John Martin when
mr. Martin had died three weeks ago he'd
been taking elixir X for diabetes had
given up his insulin injections for this
simplified sure-shot cure-all hadn't
consulted his doctor of course Kennedy
sealing the remnants as evidence assigns
a sample number and identifies the seal
with his initials but the word of the
wife of the deceased is not enough a
chain of evidence must then be linked to
include a photostatic copy of the death
certificate the official cause of death
diabetes
[Music]
and now the food and drug people want to
know what is Alexa Rex what's in it in
every district station is a battery of
crack chemists and micro analysts who
fight the battle against filth and fraud
- one of these comes Alexa Rex
the magic formula to relieve sickness
and pain turns out to be nothing more
than a mixture of water and an alcoholic
extract of certain aura basis weeds that
grow in profusion in the makers backyard
it is instantly clear to the district
chief that elixir X is a flagrant
violation of the law but it must be
decided officially before he can issue a
citation against the manufacturer the
evidence must be weighed by medical
officers in Washington here Food and
Drug physicians consider the matter from
a purely medical view what according to
a consensus of the group will this
mixture do for any of the following
diabetes arthritis or any of the aches
and pains and guarantees to cure the
answer is a flat unequivocal nothing
the law moves swiftly the maker has a
chance to show cause why he should not
be prosecuted but there is little he can
do to refute the evidence the maker
receives a year in jail and a stiff fine
too late to help John Martin but not too
late to protect the lives and health of
others and so another result of Bureau
vigilance rests among the rogues gallery
of typical frauds brought to book two
look at this display you would think the
nation is susceptible to anything
unfortunately there is opportunity to
prey on the ignorant and unsuspecting
people who cannot afford or who spurn a
doctor's advice or easy marks for
extravagant claims or weird devices to
have as much effect as a spell cast by a
witch doctor the inventor of this
electrical gimmick claimed great healing
qualities for colored lights just bask
in the glow your misery calls for and
you're as good as new
it's almost unbelievable that he sold
thousands of these a cheese distributor
did a brisk business in imported Swiss
or at least the label said it was
imported he wound up getting a longer
trip than the cheese took
now curbing violations takes a lot of
coordination of Department forces a
Planning Division in Washington plots
investigations on a geographical and
time basis so that representative plants
are checked regularly in every area even
such things as economic trends play a
part a crop failure due to weather for
example puts the agency on the alert
against inferior products going into
canned or bottled goods
inspectors are authorized to enter
without advance notice a food or drug
plant doing interstate business
virtually all have college degrees and a
science such as chemistry bacteriology
or biology at fishing ports a
distributor never knows when his frozen
Filat line will be tested a single flip
will tell the trained inspector if this
is one that should have got away nothing
takes precedence over FDA in deciding
what shall enter the country from abroad
a sample of every shipment is examined
here olives are being selected at random
[Music]
if there's anything foreign besides the
rum and these bottles this candling
process will reveal it
expert T testers who have devoted a
lifetime to their work set minimum
standards for all brands in Washington
meanwhile is a tremendous laboratory
which not only backs up the corps of
inspectors but constantly pursues
projects of its own here in the division
of microbiology are samples of virtually
every growing thing known to man through
which analysts can determine to almost
fantastic lengths what foreign elements
may be in a suspected product
literally anything can be detected from
a microscopic fragment of a fly's wing
down to a wispy minuscule of a dandelion
but here too they decide on standards
for such things as surgical sutures and
adhesive tape how sticky should Stevie
now one of the marks of our so-called
enlightened civilization has been the
development and interest in vitamin
products but big-time promotion has
resulted in possible abuses which the
vitamin division seeks to control it is
important therefore to determine whether
a product is what it alleges to be and
will do the job it claims
[Music]
constant experiments are made not only
to certify commercial products but to
probe theories of the department
scientists here is a test made on white
mites from the same litter those which
have been getting a certain vitamin grow
large and strong those deprived of it
are weak and puny consider now the
life-saving drugs that deserve the label
of wonder or miracle products penicillin
and the newer streptomycin these must
never be allowed to waver from the
knife-edge path of purity and potency
every pharmaceutical house that
manufactures them must submit for
analysis a sample of each batch made
before they can be distributed
and it is almost a full-time concern of
the division of food control to what
lengths well there's a man who's
interested in how tender a tough grape
garden pea should be if his teeth won't
tell him for sure he's got a gadget that
will if it's too hard
it isn't top grade and may not be sold
as such because the war greatly advanced
synthetic chemistry new compounds for
crop or soil improvement are in wide use
Department experts want to know if
flavor and nutritional safety are
affected
with American women spending millions of
dollars yearly on cosmetics FDA is
intent on preventing the price of beauty
from becoming tragically high the files
in Washington offer a mute testimony and
painful proof that despite their lovely
packaging and glowing claims some of the
bland at innocent-looking pastes and
powders not only are worthless but
health hazards there is no attempt to
disclaim that a product will improve
upon nature it is just that every beauty
preparation in the interstate market
must pass a rigid safety test
as long as their country cousins don't
see them these bunnies have nothing to
worry about it seems someone has an idea
for a hair coding preparation and FDA
wants to study of great importance is
the work done by the color certification
Division a large percentage of our food
drugs and cosmetics are colored by dyes
and it is vital to know their
derivations coal tar dyes in certain
mixtures can be extremely dangerous if
not pure or use properly every
manufacturer must submit samples for
certifications before using them
here then is where the real ingredients
of satisfaction are determined we're men
of science provide fact or fallacy for
claims and labels that read best by test
or finest available not a day goes by
when we do not profit by their zeal and
watchfulness our standard of living
waving higher and higher for certainly
it can be said that nowhere in the world
can people buy with more confidence or
use with greater safety the thousand and
one products which go into their daily
lives
so let these tireless feet be a symbol a
symbol of a nation's concern for its
consumers and assurance that all its
ramparts of safety are able a defendant
for this to is part of our heritage
this too is a battle that must be waged
and won a battle against deceit and
fraud and sometimes nature
this is vigilance and it's attentive
best safeguarding the health and welfare
of a nation
[Music]